[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous allons à la rencontre
dan Gaëlle qui a bénéficié du dispositif
AFI l'aide financière à l'insertion une
aide facultative réservée aux
bénéficiaires du RSA ne pouvant émerger
au dispositif de droit commun afin de
sécuriser leur parcours d'insertion
voyons ça
[Musique]
l'aide financière à l'insertion permet
de faciliter le parcours d'insertion des
BRSA par le financement de tous types de
dépenses autre que la formation comme
par exemple pour la santé le logement
les équipements et certaines difficultés
financières
bonjour Anne-Gaëlle bonjour Alexandre
alors vous avez pu bénéficier de la fi à
quoi vous asservissez
mes frais d'inscription l'équipe
pédagogique et mes frais de transport et
comment avez-vous fait pour bénéficier
de cette aide pour bénéficier de cette
aide je me suis rendue ici au service
prévention d'insertion j'ai rencontré
une conseillère qui m'a orienté vers
l'aide de la firmière comme je suis
bénéficiaire du RSA belle m'a aidé en
fin compte à monter un dossier toutou
pour
comédie de cette aide et comment vous
auriez fait sans cette aide j'aurais pas
pu continuer
mon moi ma formation dans la coiffure
merci Anne-Gaëlle
le montant minimal de l'aide financière
à l'insertion et de 50 euros le montant
maximal d'aide et de 1000 euros tout
registre confondus parfois et par
période de 12 mois le montant de l'aide
peut atteindre 2000 euros sous réserve
d'un rapport circonstancié visé par la
direction du tas ou par la direction
centrale à référence
bonjour Philippe bonjour Alexandre alors
dites-nous qui peut bénéficier de la fi
là ici donc l'aide financier à
l'installation est une mesure du
département donc elle est ouverte au
bénéficier du RSA accompagnée par le
département dans le cadre d'un contrat
d'engagement réciproque peut aussi
bénéficier de l'IFI les bénéfices du RSA
accompagnés par le Pôle emploi dans le
cadre Roger personnalisé d'accès à
l'emploi et quel type de frais sont pris
en charge alors je dirais tout type de
frais or le financement de la formation
alors expliquez-nous quels sont les
modalités pour bénéficier de la fi donc
la fi s'effectue auprès d'un travailleur
social du département ou d'un conseiller
en incession quelquefois un rapport
social est nécessaire très bien merci
Philippe merci Alexandre
l'aide financière à l'insertion est un
petit coup de pouce qui permet au
bénéficiaire d’être plus serein et de
faciliter leur parcours d'insertion
[Musique]
si vous souhaitez en savoir davantage
sur l'aide financière à l'insertion
n'hésitez pas les coordonnées
s'affichent en ce moment même sur votre
écran le département des générations
c'est déjà fini si vous voulez revoir
cet épisode ainsi que les précédents
rendez-vous sur nos sites et nos réseaux
sociaux quant à moi je vous retrouve
très vite pour un nouvel épisode à
bientôt
la semaine prochaine on découvre le
dispositif FSL le fond de solidarité
pour le logement qui a pour objectif
d'aider les ménages en difficulté
accéder et à se maintenir les
allogements décents et indépendant
[Musique]